welcome back everyone this is screencast
4 in our series on Advanced behavioral
testing for nlu in the previous
screencast we talked about the principle
of compositionality we come now to our
point of intersection with the homework
and the associated bake off we're going
to talk about the benchmarks cogs and
recogns which are both designed to test
compositional generalization for our
models
cogs set the agenda here and then recogs
is our extension of it what we were
trying to do with recogs is first
understand why some of the
generalization splits in cogs have
proved so challenging for present-day
models and in addition reformulate Cog
somewhat so that it comes closer to
testing purely semantic phenomena and
kind of abstracting away from incidental
features of some of the logical forms
that are in cogs
let's start with the task description
we'll look at cogs first the inputs are
simple English sentences like a rose was
helped by a dog and the outputs are
logical forms that is descriptions of
the meanings of the sentences and for
cogs and recogs these are a kind of
event semantic style descriptions here
we've got rows and indefinite
corresponding to the grammatical subject
here with variable one
uh the next conjunct is help theme so
this is describing the theme argument of
the helping event and X3 is the event
variable for this helping event and X1
links back to rows identifying this Rose
as the theme
the event description also has an agent
that is identified by variable X6 and
again binds into that helping event
description X3 and X6 is identified as
being a dog
here's a similar example this one
involves the definite description the
Sailor that corresponds to this star
operator in The Logical form and
otherwise the semantics is very similar
recogs is very similar in many respects
here I've got that same first example a
rose was helped by a dog you can see
that recog's logical forms tend to be
shorter we've removed a lot of the
symbols that are associated with
variables we've reorganized the conjunct
somewhat and the event descriptions are
somewhat more transparent for example we
have a separate predication identifying
the help event and binding it to
variable X7 which is then used to
identify both the theme and the agent
here's that second example the Sailor
dusted a boy we have the star operator
for definite descriptions as well and
the other simplifications are as in the
first example
what are the motivations for both cogs
and recogs well they really tie into the
compositionality principle we have an
observation that humans easily interpret
novel combinations of familiar elements
in ways that are systematic this is so
effortless in fact that the Kong's
generalization splits are even sometimes
hard to appreciate as compositional
generalization tasks because the
relevant leaps that we need to make seem
very small indeed to us as speakers of a
language like English
the explanation for why this is so easy
and effortless for us is
compositionality that is one way of
explaining why we're able to make so
much use of Novel combinations of
familiar elements compositionality tells
us that in some sense the meanings of
those novel combinations were fully
determined by the meanings of their
parts
the core question we're trying to
address is can our best models do
compositional generalization and
relatedly have they too found
compositional solutions that would be a
more internal question about their
underlying causal mechanisms I think the
vision of cogs and recogs is that we
have behavioral tasks that can help us
resolve question three about
generalization and the hope is that if
they succeed at question 3 will have an
informed answer to the deeper question
posed in four about the nature of their
Solutions one way to think about this is
that if a model manages to succeed at a
task like cogs or recogs that can only
be that is the best explanation for that
is that they have found a compositional
solution
we should pause to more deeply
understand the cog's logical forms
because they have some interesting
features about them that actually help
explain the pattern of results that we
see in the literature
to start I kind of alluded to this
before verbs specify primitive events
that have their own core conceptual
structure and can involve one or more
obligatory or optional roles here's a
quick example our sentence is Emma broke
a vase
this is at its heart a breaking event
and The Logical Forum here is saying
that it has two participants the agent
Emma
and the theme which is the vase which is
an indefinite identified by this
predication up here
's a related English sentence the vase
broke this one is lacking its agent
argument and the theme argument has been
promoted to grammatical subject position
in the English sentence but otherwise
this is very similar
in cogs variable numbering is determined
by linear position in the input sentence
that is for example the reason that
we're using the variable X2 here for the
event description is because the verb
break which anchors that event is in
position two in the input sentence
that turns out actually to be a really
important feature of these logical forms
that seriously impacts the performance
of modern models especially ones with
positional encoding
all the variables in cogs and
recognological forms are bound
right because it looks like we have free
variables but they're all existentially
bound with widest scope so for example
whereas you have a logical form like
this where it looks like variables 1 and
2 are free variables in fact we're meant
to interpret this as though there were a
prefix of existentially Quantified
variables at the start of the logical
form
definite descriptions are also bound
they're bound more locally by that star
operator for example the Sailor ran
translates as star sailor X1 because
sailor is in the first position and
that's a complete definite description
and then that continues the Sailor being
the agent of the running event bound to
variable 2 in second position there
the Cog splits have the following
structure we have a pretty large train
set
we also have a Dev set and a test set
and both of those are IID that is their
standard evaluations in the terms that
we're using in this unit the interesting
part is this group of twenty one
thousand
generalization examples corresponding to
21 different splits each one trying to
probe models for different sort of
compositional generalization phenomena
this is a table from the paper that
enumerates all of the generalization
splits at least in some fashion they're
broken up into different categories
we've talked a bit about these before
but let me just highlight a few for this
first block here we're talking about
putting familiar phrases into new
positions for example subject to object
for common noun means that in training
we see examples like a hedgehog ate the
cake where Hedgehog is a grammatical
subject and in the generalization split
in this category we first encounter
Hedgehog in a position that is not the
subject and the others are similar for
the Primitive grammatical role splits we
see these Primitives like shark and
Paula as isolated elements in training
and then in generalization we encounter
them in full sentential context so we
have to figure out what to do with them
there are also novel combinations of
modified phrases for example object
modification to subject modification
means that modifiers like on the plate
occur in object position during the
train examples and then in subject
position in the generalization split
that turns out to be very difficult
indeed
for deeper recursion for both sentential
compliments and PP complements we see
some number of recursive depth at
training and then in generalization we
see even more depth for those kinds of
recursion
then there are some other things that
involve alternation of syntactic role
like active to passive and passive to
active
some cases like Emily baked and the
giraffe baked a cake or we have shifting
of the argument structures and so forth
and then at the bottom we have some
splits that involve verb classes
high level overview of the splits what
we did for the recogs paper is assemble
what I've hear called a synthetic
leaderboard this is just us pulling
together results from a bunch of
prominent papers in the literature that
tackled the cogs problem
let's first look all the way to the
right here at the overall column
if you look there which is a standard
move for nlpers to make just look at
overall you see what looks like a pretty
Rosy picture four cogs models are
getting up into the 80s on these
generalization splits and that looks
like they've really gotten traction
and then if you look just to the left of
that at that Lex column that's grouping
together the generalization splits that
involve lexical generalization you find
some impressively high numbers indeed so
it looks like models are really good at
those lexical tasks
but then travel with me further to the
left from there to the three columns
that we've called structural
generalization tasks object PP to
subject PP column of all zeros
CP recursion pretty much all zeros PP
recursion a similarly dismal story
this looks to me like models are simply
failing to get any traction at all
something is systematically wrong these
are not just low numbers this is an
indication of something fundamentally
being amiss about how these models are
grappling with these Cog splits
and this was really the puzzle that we
posed when we started thinking about the
recogns work what is Behind These
Columns of zero or near zero numbers
it's a very worrisome situation we want
to get to the bottom of it
the first thing we did is just observe
that there are a lot of redundant tokens
in The cog's Logical forms for example
every single variable begins with x
space underscore space and then the
numeral the numeral is the only
distinguishing feature of that variable
and so what we decided to do is simply
remove it and replace it with just a one
there
this has a profound effect on the
performance of models even though it's
an obviously semantics preserving change
to The Logical forms and I think we can
think in terms of basic conditional
probabilities to come to an
understanding of why this matters so
much think just at the level of bigram
frequency for cogs overwhelmingly the
commonest bigram in the data set is
comma X and that's because so many of
these Expressions involve variables
inside those parenthetical expressions
with commas and then way down with much
smaller frequency are commas with names
next to them
when we make these adjustments to The
Logical forms everything evens out much
more those variables are still prominent
1 4 6 and 3 but notice that a proper
name Emma the most frequent proper name
in the cogs data set is now on par with
those variables and overall we're seeing
a much evener picture which is a much
happier state for language models to be
in because they are so dependent on
these kind of local conditional
probabilities
and since this makes for a happier data
set and is obviously semantics
preserving we decided to go ahead and
remove those tokens that's a simple one
that helps mainly with lexical
generalization splits but it is not
especially impactful for those really
persistently hard structural splits
let's turn to them now first question
what is behind the zeros for CP and PP
recursion that was one of the hardest
structural generalization splits
here we should think first about length
the fundamental observation here is that
models are exposed to one kind of
example length during training and a
very distant different distribution of
lengths during the generalization splits
in particular the longest examples occur
in the generalization splits here we're
showing the distribution for input
sentences the generalization split
lengths are in green and they have this
very long tail out to very long examples
here are the output lfs same thing look
at the green examples you can see that
the generalization ones are much much
longer we have again this very long tail
of very long examples
now I should be clear I think it's
perfectly reasonable to be pushing
models to generalize to ever greater
lengths at test time this is
persistently hard for many models and we
should compel the field to find ways to
address that limitation
but remember our goal was to test for CP
and PP recursion and we can now see that
that recursion question has been totally
entwined with this question about length
generalization
and we wanted to separate them apart so
to decouple length from depth we
concatenate existing examples and
re-index the variable names using the
cogs protocol to cover all of the
variable names that we end up seeing at
test time because remember one feature
of this length issue is that not only
positions that remain untrained during
training and then end up appearing
relevant during testing but also the
names of the variables right if the
longest sequence you had in cog's
training LED you to have variable name
45 and you encounter 46 at test time
then not only are the associated
positions corresponding to random
embeddings but also that token itself
has a random
Vector associated with it in virtue of
the fact that it never appeared during
training again it's fine to push models
to overcome that problem but here you
can see it's coupled together with this
recursion question and we decoupled them
by simply augmenting examples by
concatenating them together and
adjusting the variable names accordingly
and what we find is that that
essentially completely overcomes the
problem for both lstms and for
Transformers the performance that we
reach is well above the previous state
of the art on this recursion problem
what this suggests to us is that the
hard aspect of this split is not
recursion which we were trying to test
for but rather this persistent issue
about length generalization an important
lesson about that column of zeros there
second hard question what is behind the
zeros for PP modifiers remember that was
literally a column of zeros in our
synthetic leaderboard here's our
hypothesis about what's happening four
cogs the train data actually teach the
model that PPS occur only with a
specific set of variables and positions
when models learn this lesson they then
struggle with examples that contradict
it every experience that these models
have with these PP modifiers suggest
that they have a very limited
distribution and then at generalization
time we confront them with the fact that
that distribution was misleading I think
that poses some pretty deep questions
about what's fair in terms of posing a
compositional generalization task but at
the same time we have diagnosed I think
why we have all those zeros
to further that argument what we did is
take original Cog sentences and
manipulate them in various ways so that
PPS would associate with a wider range
of linear positions and correspondingly
a wider range of variable names we have
various tricks for doing that for
example we can pre-pose object noun
phrases to get sentences like the box in
the tent Emma was Lent
topicalization is a pretty routine
operation on English objects and here we
have simply implemented that it has no
effect on the underlying semantic
representation but for cogs it has the
effect of Shifting around the variable
names in addition to get a fuller
coverage of variable names and positions
and so forth we also have interjections
so we simply stick in ohms in various
random points in the input sentences
it's a meaning preserving operation it's
just a filled pause but again it has the
effect of Shifting around the variable
names and Associated positions and to
further cover the space we also do this
thing with participle so instead of
having just standard prepositional
modifiers we also do things like a leaf
painting the spaceship again to fill in
the gaps in these variable names and
positions
the result is a very large performance
increase for both lstms and Transformers
on these splits again suggesting that
our hypothesis is on the right track and
kind of functionally the blocker here
was that models had been taught that PPS
associate with certain variable names
and certain positions which is not
precisely what we were hoping to test
for
on the basis of these insights we
perform some modifications to cogs to
get recogs this is a kind of high-level
summary of what we did Imagine an input
sentence Mia ate a cake
the cogs LF looks like this we did that
redundant token removal that I described
before mostly focused on the variable
names we did some meaning preserving
data augmentation of the sort I
described for the CP and PP recursion
cases and then we introduced this notion
of arbitrary variable naming so recog's
examples do not have variable names that
are tied to the position in the input
string rather they're kind of randomly
aside in a semantically consistent way
and we have many more examples as a
result in an effort to teach models to
abstract away from the precise names of
variables
so for our given example here we end up
with a recognological form that looks
like the one at the bottom of this slide
and the overall effect of performance is
kind of summarized in the diagram on the
right here for cog's lfs we have this
really challenging aspect that
structural generalization tasks have
dismal performance
the Redundant token removal doesn't
really affect that as you can see in
these two low red bars but meaning
preserving data augmentation and
arbitrary variable renaming do
dramatically improve performance on
those structural generalization splits
with the net effect of kind of evening
out performance across these two aspects
of the Cog slash recogs problem
here's a summary of the results we have
lstms on the top Transformers on the
bottom my high level takeaway here is
that recogs is not necessarily an easier
task in fact some aspects of it are
actually harder looking according to our
experiments than cogs but what we have
done is even outperformance and show
that it's possible to get traction on
those totally recalcitrant structural
generalization splits that led to that
really strange situation for the
literature before with those columns of
all zeros so overall we think that this
is a healthier Benchmark to hill climb
on and that seems good as well because
reconcs is just getting us closer to
testing the semantic phenomena that we
care about
to wrap up the screencast I thought it
would pose some conceptual questions
that still linger for me having done
this deep dive on cogs and recogs
first how can we test for meaning if
we're predicting logical forms logical
forms are just more syntactic
Expressions we want to get at the true
meaning we have to do that through
logical forms and The Logical forms
always have some arbitrariness about
them that's always going to get in the
way of us really purely seeing whether
models understand the meanings of these
input sentences
what is a fair generalization test in
the current context you know a lot of
our insights about compositionality
start to border on things that might
look like they are unfair in the sense
of my earlier screencasts in this unit
because we are deliberately holding out
from the training experiences some
examples that we expect the model to
Grapple with at test time
for example models are shown a world
that manifests a specific restriction
like PPS appear only in object position
and then asked to Grapple with the world
in which they also appear in subject
positions and the hard part about this
is that in some of these cases where we
restrict the training experiences we
want models to learn the not not to
learn those restrictions as in the Cog
splits whereas in other cases we do want
them to learn those restrictions and
actually just conceptually figuring out
for different phenomena which category
they fall into seems extremely difficult
to me
what are the limits of compositionality
for humans and how should that inform
our generalization tests maybe that's
the ultimate ground truth here you know
we have an assumption that natural
languages are compositional but that's a
very strong assumption it surely has
some limitations and so maybe the thing
to do is figure out where and how humans
generalize and where they don't and then
just set up a general expectation that
our models will be able to follow suit
but that poses many conceptual questions
for example if we have goals that are
not supported by our data sets but that
seem like good goals for models to reach
how should we express that in our tasks
and in our models we expect these issues
to be embodied in the data in the
examples but here we have goals that
seem to reach beyond what we can encode
in examples especially given the
variation that we see in 2B and 2C
I don't have answers to these questions
but I find it exciting that we can pose
them and that we have models that might
plausibly be on their way to achieving
something like the compositional
generalization that we are actually
seeking